[Music]
and there will be a welcome from the
presiding officer
your majesties
members
law officers
distinguished guests
it is with great sorrow that we gather
today to mourn the passing of her
majesty queen elizabeth
on behalf of all members of the scottish
parliament i would like to convey our
sincere condolences to your majesty to
the queen consort and to all members of
the royal family
not only leading our national mourning
but grieving for a much-loved mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
the thoughts of this parliament and the
people of scotland
are with the royal family at this time
of grief
but although we meet today at this time
of sadness this moment provides us with
an opportunity to to reflect on her
majesty's remarkable life and in
particular her bond with this parliament
we're reminded of her majesty's
commitment to an affection for this
parliament every time we sit
on our establishment in 1999
her majesty gifted the chamber gifted
the parliament the beautiful mace which
sits in the well of the chamber
the words inscribed on it integrity
compassion wisdom and justice
have guided and inspired us and will
continue to do so
and these values were clearly reflected
throughout her majesty's life
her majesty described this parliament as
being rightly anchored in the history of
scotland
and spoke of the grit determination
humor and forthrightness of the people
these were qualities that occupied a
personal place in her own and family's
affections
and generations of people here in
scotland reciprocated that affection
and while today is a day of sadness of
reflection
an expression of our sincere sympathy it
is also a day to recognise and be
thankful for her majesty's long reign
her service to this country and her
friendship to this parliament
for in her we have indeed had a true
friend and supporter
with us at every step from our first
opening ceremony in 1999
to the opening of each subsequent
session
and on our important anniversaries too
the pandemic meant that our opening
ceremony last year was delayed from its
usual summer date to october
and covet meant that precautions were in
place
but her majesty was determined to join
us and demonstrated the importance of
her relationship with the parliament and
the people
we 129 members
each invited a community representative
a local hero to be a guest at that
ceremony in recognition of their
selfless service to those in need during
the pandemic
her majesty stopped and spoke with every
single local hero waiting for her asking
about their contribution and thanking
them sincerely for their efforts
young and old from the length and
breadth of scotland
their delight and pride her receiving
her majesty's time and interest
was abundantly clear
a true demonstration of the time queen
elizabeth invested in the relationship
with this parliament and the people
in my role representing the parliament i
was privileged to enjoy two private
audiences with her majesty following my
appointment in 2021
and i very much valued her insight and
her wise counsel
so while we mourn today with the royal
family and with the people of scotland
and others far beyond
we also give thanks as a nation
and as a parliament
for her majesty queen elizabeth queen of
scots for her extraordinary life and
work
and before i invite the first minister
to move the motion of condolence i would
ask you to join me
in two-minute silence and please stand
as you were able
so
thank you
thank you
today's business is consideration of a
motion of condolence in the name of
nicolas sturgeon and i now call on
nicolas sturgeon first minister of
scotland to speak to and move the motion
of condolence
your majesty's presenting officer
members of parliament honoured guests
it is my solemn duty
and
my honor to move this motion of
condolence on the death of her majesty
queen elizabeth
for people across our country this is a
time of profound sorrow
while the nation's grief is for our
queen
the royal families is for their beloved
mother grandmother and great-grandmother
today on behalf of the parliament and
people of scotland i offer my heartfelt
condolences to your majesties and to the
duke of rothsie the princess royal the
earls of inverness and forfeir and to
all members of her majesty's wider
family
when queen victoria died in 1901
arthur balfour led tributes then in the
house of commons
he commented that the grief of the
country was in part because they were
marking the end of an epoch
the beginning of which stretches beyond
the memory of any individual whom i am
now addressing
those words are just as true for us
today
most of us simply do not remember life
without the queen
when as princess elizabeth she gave a
radio broadcast from south africa on her
21st birthday she was addressing an
empire that still included india
when she became monarch winston
churchill was prime minister
in an ever-changing and often turbulent
world her majesty has been our constant
she has been the anchor of our
nation our personal recollections are
often intertwined with memories of her
reign
i was
nine years old when i first saw the
queen
she visited irvin my hometown in july
1979
to open the magnum leisure centre
i was one of hundreds lining the streets
with my mum and by luck we ended up
close to her car as it passed by
nine-year-old me was absolutely
convinced i had caught her eye
that nine-year-old girl could not have
imagined
more than 35 years later
being in the front passenger seat of
another car this time with the queen at
the wheel
driving through the balmoral estate
in recent days other leaders have shared
stories from balmoral
of barbecues cooked by prince philip as
the queen laid the table
these are
memories i treasure too
special times in what was clearly their
happy place
i did however
experience
one rather tense moment at balmoral
my husband and i were with the queen
before dinner
when the drawing room light started to
flicker
to my great alarm he was after all in
the presence of her majesty my husband
suddenly leapt up and darted across the
room
peter had spotted the cause of the
flickering light
one of the queen's young corgis a
beautiful pup called sandy was eating
through a lamp switch
thankfully
tragedy was averted and sandy emerged
unscathed though not before the stern
ticking off from his mistress
just like
all my predecessors as first minister
and all prime ministers i deeply valued
the time i spent alone with the queen
her words of wisdom
counsel
and humor will stay in my heart for the
rest of my life
however the memory i cherish most is not
from balmoral or from audiences at
hollywood
it is from 2015 when the queen opened
the borders railway
i spent the journey from edinburgh to
tweed bank with just her and prince
philip enjoying the recollections of
times spent in scotland
now that would have been special on any
day
that it was also the day the queen
became our longest reigning monarch
allowing me to observe closely how
quietly reflective she was about that
historic milestone
made it so much more so
it was one of the great privileges of my
life
what was obvious then and on every
occasion she graced us with her presence
was the queen's genuine love of scotland
indeed her first official visit was here
in scotland when she opened the aberdeen
sailors home in october 1944.
in the decades since the queen has been
intrinsic to the story of modern
scotland
from the opening of the forties oil
pipeline to the fourth bridge and later
the queensferry crossing the borders
railway and the hosting of three
commonwealth games she was present at so
many of our iconic moments
she was also a true and steadfast friend
of this parliament
on the day we reconvened in 1999 she
allowed the title queen elizabeth queen
of scots to be used
she also presented us with our treasured
mace its words wisdom
justice
compassion integrity
describe values personified by the queen
throughout her entire life
even as her health declined her majesty
inspired us with an unfaltering
dedication to public service
in his address on friday the king
recalled his mother's words on her 21st
birthday
my whole life whether it be long or
short shall be devoted to your service
for 75 years queen elizabeth more than
fulfilled that vow
she performed her duties with dedication
wisdom and a profound sense of service
she set an exceptional example to all of
us
our nation is in mourning today for a
queen whose loss we have not yet begun
to come to terms with
we are deeply honoured by the presence
today of his majesty king charles iii
and the queen concert
your majesty we stand ready to support
you as you continue your own life of
service and as you build on the
extraordinary legacy of your beloved
mother
our queen
queen elizabeth queen of scots
we are grateful for her life
may she now rest in peace
i now call on douglas ross leader of the
scottish conservative and unionist party
your majesty's presiding officer
the news from balmoral on thursday
evening rocked us to the core
her late majesty queen elizabeth ii was
a constant presence in our lives
throughout her 70-year reign
for many of us it's difficult to imagine
our country without her
the queen seemed as permanent as the
stones of edinburgh castle a constant
while her country around her changed
when queen elizabeth ii became monarch
winston churchill was prime minister
and she was served in that role by 15
political leaders
offering them a wealth of wise counsel
from her long experience
from the queen who lived through the
great depression and the great recession
the second world war and the second gulf
war
the length of the queen's reign meant
that she was an anchor to our history
ensuring that whatever changes to our
country and how we lived our lives we
retained an enduring link to the
generations that had come before
she was a living reminder of the
sacrifices made to build the country and
the world that we live in today
what other leader could have reassured
the nation in the darkest days of the
covered pandemic
by drawing on their own memories of
children being separated from families
during the blitz
time and time again her majesty gave us
certainty
stability
joy and happiness when we needed it most
that's why the scenes that we saw on the
final journey from balmoral to holyrood
palace yesterday surprised no one
from the heart of aberdeenshire to our
capital city
young and old came together to pay their
respects
scotland's unique tributes saw tractors
and horses interspersed with members of
the public who came in their tens of
thousands to line the route
because while monarch of the united
kingdom and the commonwealth
we know the late queen held scotland
close to her heart and we held her to
ours
we feel the pain of her loss so strongly
with her new king and the entire royal
family today
as they agree on a personal level we
join them in mourning as a nation
in her final speech to this chamber the
late queen said
it is often said that it is the people
that make a place and there are few
places where this is truer
than in scotland
but i think we can also see that the
queen shaped modern scotland during her
70-year reign
and we know that the bonds and ties to
scotland developed and strengthened by
the late monarch will be continued by
king charles iii
euser became the first sovereign to
exceed the throne while on scottish soil
in over 400 years you have already
served scotland with great dedication as
duke of rossi duke of edinburgh earl of
carrick baron of renfrew lord of the
isles and prince and great steward of
scotland
and i know that people across the
country will show you the same support
and devotion as they did your late
mother
because today we don't just commemorate
the reign of our queen but also
celebrate the life of a woman who many
in scotland knew and loved
who dedicated her life to her country
to duty
and to serving others
on behalf of the scottish conservatives
i'm proud to support the motion of
condolence today
to thank queen elizabeth ii for a long
loyal and dignified service
and to offer our full support and
loyalty
to our new king
may her late majesty queen elizabeth ii
rest in glorious and eternal peace and
from all of us sir god save the king
i now call on anna sarwar leader of the
scottish labour party
your majesty i offer my sincerest
condolences on the passing of your
beloved mother and my thoughts remain
with you the queen concert your son's
grandchildren and all the royal family
at this time of deep sadness
first and foremost the queen was a
mother
and i cannot imagine the intense feeling
of personal loss you're experiencing
while fulfilling your devotion to public
service as our king
i hope it gives you and your family much
comfort that we are all grieving the
passing of someone who was so special
cherished and loved by us all
her majesty was a constant in our lives
many saw her as family
many saw their family in her
she reminded me of my own grandmother
and her walk
her demeanor even the way she held her
handbag
but she also touched generations
i returned home on thursday night
to a crying six-year-old
who said he was sad because he will
never get to meet
the queen
queen elizabeth ii was also a constant
reminder
of the need for kindness and compassion
in our society
so often in our politics both today and
throughout history we focus on what
divides us
but from the blitz to the pandemic the
queen brought our nation together
she was the great unifier of our country
she brought joy at times of national
pride
she brought comfort at times of national
tragedy
and she brought light at our nation's
darkest moments
we will never forget
how her majesty the queen found the
words during the pandemic to remind us
all that we will meet our loved ones
again
words which are more poignant than ever
following the passing of our husband
prince philip your father
who now rests at peace
with his beloved little bit
we know how much she loved scotland
and we loved her back
she reminded this parliament that
despite our political disagreements and
arguments all of us here are in service
of the scottish people and her influence
was felt far beyond these shores with
the people of the commonwealth and other
nations united in grief at this time
our world changed beyond recognition
during her reign
but her dedication to duty her integrity
her warmth and her service to others
never wavered
in fact politicians here and right
around the world will look on enviously
in 70 years of service as our head of
state
she always seemed to say the right thing
do the right thing
and at the right time
and i am confident as we enter a new era
we will cherish your majesty's
leadership
and your wisdom compassion integrity
and justice
timeless values passed down to you by
your mother but also gifted to us on our
parliamentary mace
we wish you a long and happy reign
god save the king
i now call on patrick harvey co-leader
of the scottish green party
the experience of loss is universal
it comes into all of our lives it's a
reminder that the reality of human life
is not rooted in status or in title
but in the connections we make bonds of
love and friendship of family and of
service to one
another people of all views can respect
this whatever else we may disagree about
so in this moment as we mark the death
of the queen i offer my parties sincere
condolences to her son to all of his
family and to all those whose lives she
touched
for many people a monarch stands as a
symbol of the country
if this is true
then this is a moment
more than one of personal loss for those
we stand with in their grief
it's also a time to reflect on the
change the queen witnessed during such a
long reign
when princess elizabeth of york became
queen elizabeth ii the uk was still
early in its recovery from a brutal
world war and had begun laying the
foundations of something extraordinary
a welfare state and a national health
service to tackle the giant evils of the
age
nearly three decades of declining
inequality followed
at the last coronation the oath still
referred to other countries as the
possessions of an empire and here at
home human rights and equality were
distant ideas
with racist discrimination remaining
legal and people treated as criminals
and outcasts because of their sexuality
now we can look back and celebrate
extraordinary progressive change even as
we must continue to defend what has been
achieved
there are those for whom the long reign
of elizabeth ii and indeed the
institution of monarchy represent
continuity stability
permanence
but in truth the tide of progress cannot
be halted
it feels slow as we live it day by day
but in time it is dramatic
so presiding officer as charles iii
begins his reign let us hope indeed
redouble our determination that he will
have the opportunity to witness change
just as transformational and more it is
still needed
i now call on alex cole hamilton leader
of the scottish liberal democrats
presiding officer your majesties we do
not choose the life to which we are born
and seldom do we shape the events that
define our times we can only hope to
move through life with humility and
close regard for those around us to get
to conduct ourselves in the time that we
are given with compassion with kindness
and with grace
the life of her majesty queen elizabeth
ii was a towering example of all of
those qualities manifest in a single
human being
she always kept a special place for
scotland in her heart as we intend or
she in turn found ample room in ours
her passing leaves a profound absence
across our family of nations and these
islands are united in our grief her
majesty came of age
in the crucible of war a period of
gravest danger for our country
it fostered in her a deep commitment to
reconciliation to peace and a common
understanding among nations so evident
in her commitment to the commonwealth
it's why she told the listening world
from cape town on the occasion of that
21st birthday broadcast that while she
was 6 000 miles away from the country of
her birth she was never far from home
and hence the grief that we feel today
is shared across the world
from the blitz to the pandemic through
times of tempest and times of calm
sustained as always by the duke of
edinburgh her beloved strength and stay
she was the embodiment of constancy and
forbearance in the face of remarkable
change
she sat with presidents and hospital
patients key workers and veterans she
left from helicopters and dined with
bears
she earned the widespread affection that
has been so visible in these days of
mourning
in one christmas broadcast her majesty
said
not all of us can do great things but we
can all do small things with great love
presiding officer your majesties
the measure of the her example inspired
so many of us to fulfill the promise of
those words on behalf of the scottish
liberal democrats i express our deepest
condolences to his majesty the king to
the royal family and affirm our
allegiance to both god save the king
and i now invite his majesty the king to
respond to the motion of condolence
presiding officer
first minister
party leaders and members of the
scottish parliament
i know that the scottish parliament and
the people of scotland
share with me a profound sense
of grief at the death of my beloved
mother
through all the years of her reign
the queen like so many
generations of our family before her
found in the hills of this land
and in the hearts of its people
a haven
and a home
my mother felt as i do the
greatest admiration for the scottish
people
for their magnificent achievements
and their indomitable spirit
and it was the greatest comfort for her
to know in turn
the true affection
in which she was held
the knowledge of that deep and abiding
bond
must be to us a solace
as we mourn the end of a life of
incomparable service
if i might paraphrase the words of the
great robert burns
my dear mother was
the friend of man the friend of truth
the friend of age
and guide of youth
few hearts like hers with virtue warmed
few heads with knowledge so informed
while still very young
the queen pledged herself to serve her
country
and her people
and to maintain the principles of
constitutional government
as we now mark with gratitude a promise
most faithfully fulfilled
i am determined with god's help
and with yours
to follow that inspiring example
the title
of duke of rossi and the other scottish
titles which i've had the honor
to carry for so long
i now pass to my eldest son william who
i know will be as proud
as i have been to bear the symbols of
this ancient kingdom
i take up my new duties with
thankfulness
for all that scotland has given me
with resolve to seek always the welfare
of our country
and his people
and with wholehearted trust
in your goodwill
and good counsel
as we take forward that task together
thank you
thank you your majesty
i now close this meeting off the
parliament
the piper
of the scottish parliament
piper stuart macmillan
who
is himself a member of the scottish
parliament now plays
as the king
retires in the company of the presiding
officer
with the queen consort
and with those who have
come in procession
the heralds in first place then lord
lion king of arms
and then on this occasion the duke of
hamilton
in his kilt but not carrying the crown
because earlier today
he placed it
upon queen elizabeth ii at rest
instant giles
[Music]
the tune highland cathedral
in lament
to
the late queen
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
queen
remembered
by
the parliament that she opened and the
parliament that
has now served scotland for many years
powerful messages particularly from the
first minister
who brought in so many recollections
particularly when she was nine years old
and saw the queen
and then later on became the queen's
first minister and was driven by the
queen
across the balmoral estate
but for the king
the king of scots who takes on that
title that the queen gave permission to
have used
in scotland
a title that reminds all of us that
scotland was never conquered
it was always
a land where the people
were the story
and held the sway
and just as robert bruce king of scots
mary queen of scots james king of scots
the whole number of them
so
elizabeth she may have been elizabeth ii
at the will of the united kingdom
parliament
but in scotland
she was elizabeth queen of scots
waiting outside to see the king of a few
of the families of the msps
gates opening now
as the officer commanding
the royal company of archers here
prepared to see the king leave
it's been a very long day for